the resurrection of Jesus offers answers
to more of the big questions than any
other event in history does God exist if
so does he care about us is there life
after death do Miracles occur can we
know what's true does life have meaning
how should we live we had our answers to
these questions when a group of women
showed up at the Tomb of Jesus and were
greeted by an Angel who
saido not be afraid for I know that you
are looking for Jesus who is crucified
he is not here he has risen just as he
said with so many different World Views
competing for attention here in the 21st
century I have to say that having a
verifiable miracle and God's stamp of
approval at the core of Christianity is
like watching a bunch of people SC
scambling around to find some buried
treasure when you've got the missing
piece of the treasure map the piece
where X or rather across marks the spot
I find it fascinating that atheists
dogmatically insist that the message of
Christianity is just put your Blind
Faith in our religion when Christianity
more than any other world view I'm aware
of has always said here's how you can
know that this is true
in the book of Acts the Apostle Paul
tells the people of Athens that God has
set a day when he will judge the world
with Justice by the man he has appointed
he has given proof of this to everyone
by raising him from the dead so if
Christians Proclaim here's the proof why
do atheists here just believe without
any evidence
whatsoever it's as if they're not
listening it's as if hearing they do not
hear and seeing they do not see but for
those with ears to hear knowing that
Jesus rose from the dead is actually
much simpler than many people realize to
know that Jesus rose from the dead we
only need to know two things one that he
was really dead and two that he was
alive again
later if Jesus was dead and he was alive
again in later I'd say that our atheist
friends have a great big Son of God
shaped hole in their
worldview was Jesus dead and I mean
really dead not passed out not in a coma
not in a brief state of cardiac arrest
was he
dead yes yes he was now the new
generation of atheists who learn about
Christianity primarily from social media
may be surprised to learn that there are
historical facts about Jesus they think
of Jesus as a mythical figure like
Hercules except that they're much
angrier about Jesus for some reason it's
a tragedy of the internet age that
positions that would be laughed out of
the room at the scholarly level can
become quite popular at the internet
level by circulating among people who
don't know much about anything at the
scholarly level Jesus myther are viewed
along the same lines as Holocaust
deniers but at the internet level every
other atheist I run into says Jesus
never
existed really well what books have you
read on this none but I watch like three
YouTube videos so I'm obviously far more
knowledgeable than every respected
scholar on the
planet meanwhile even some of the most
critical historical Jesus Scholars will
acknowledge certain fact facts about
Jesus that he was baptized by John the
Baptist that he had disciples that he
was known as a miracle worker and an
exorcist that he believed he played a
crucial role in the coming of the
kingdom of God and of course that he
died by
crucifixion the scholarly consensus on
Jesus death arises from having a variety
of ancient sources there are Christian
Jewish and Roman sources reporting Jesus
death and and knowing how crucifixion
works today we tend to think of
crucifixion as just nailing someone to a
cross but Roman crucifixion was a
three-step process the first step was
the scourging which was sometimes called
the half death because victims would be
half dead by the time it was finished
the Romans used a flagrum made of
leather thongs with chunks of bone or
metal woven into the strands designed to
remove human flesh we have records of
people being beaten until their veins
and arteries were exposed or until their
bones were showing or until their
intestines Spilled Out and that was just
the beginning step two was nailing the
victim to a cross and letting him hang
there while the blood drained out of him
once he stopped gasping for breath the
Romans knew their work was
done almost
the Romans didn't take crucifixion
lightly so there was a third step some
sort of death blow just to make sure
their victim was dead if they needed to
pry someone off a cross they would smash
his head in or stab him through the
heart with a sword or a spear or set him
on fire or let wild animals rip him
apart not the sort of process anyone's
going to walk away from so Jesus death
isn't simply a point of Christian
doctrine it's a fact of history as even
non-Christian Scholars are happy to
admit atheist New Testament scholar G
ludeman declares that Jesus death as a
consequence of crucifixion is
indisputable John Dominic crosson of the
infamous Jesus seminar says that there
is not the slightest doubt about the
fact of Jesus crucifixion under Pontius
Pilate Marcus Borg another member of the
Jesus seminar St atates that Jesus
execution is the most certain fact about
the historical Jesus Jewish scholar
Pinkus leaped affirms that Jesus death
by crucifixion is historically certain
according to Paula Frederickson a
convert to Judaism the single most solid
fact about Jesus life is his death he
was executed by the Roman prefect pilate
on or around Passover in the manner Rome
reserved particularly for political
insurrection s namely
crucifixion and as everyone's favorite
scholarly critic of Christianity Bart
Man maintains one of the most certain
facts of history is that Jesus was
crucified on orders of the Roman prefect
of Judea ponus
pilate the real question then is whether
Jesus was alive again
later how would we know if Jesus was
alive at some point following his
execution by the Romans the same way we
know many other things from history we
need Witnesses and we need to know that
we can trust these
Witnesses do we have witnesses of the
Risen Jesus yes Lots fortunately they
began preaching almost immediately and
we have summaries of some of their early
sermons they issued official credle
statements that could be easily
memorized and passed on to others they
sent out Representatives with
authoritative Traditions Traditions that
would eventually be incorporated into
the gospels and other writings we also
have writings and quotations outside the
New Testament from the next generation
of Christian leaders which included
people like Clement of Rome and polycarp
who knew one or more of the Apostles and
who continued preaching the message of
the Apostles especially the resurrection
of Jesus
but the most interesting Source on the
eyewitnesses of the Risen Jesus is an
early Christian Creed recorded in 1
Corinthians 15
3-7 1 Corinthians was written around
ad55 and Paul says in the letter that he
had already delivered the Creed to the
church in Corinth which would have been
around ad.
51 but Paul received the Creed long
before that either when he visited the
apostles in Jerusalem or perhaps even at
his conversion and Scholars date its
formulation to within a few years of
Jesus
crucifixion James DG dun writes this
tradition we can be entirely confident
was formulated as tradition within
months of Jesus death according to
Michael goulder Paul received the
tradition that is he was taught it at
his conversion perhaps 2 years after
Jesus death rri vilkins says that the
Creed indu ly goes back to the oldest
phase of all in the history of primitive
Christianity gett ludman maintains that
the elements in the tradition are to be
dated to the first two years after the
crucifixion of Jesus Paul Barnett dates
the Creed to within two or three years
of the first Easter Richard burd and
Graham G say it dates from only a few
years after Jesus death Robert Funk and
the Jesus seminar put it within two or
three years at most Richard Hayes says
it originates within about 3 years after
Jesus was crucified in Jerusalem and
Alexander wedderburn says that it goes
back to the first half of the
30s so there's widespread agreement
among Scholars from across the
theological spectrum that 1 Corinthians
15 contains very early material that can
be traced to Jesus original disciples
shortly after his death let's read the
passage Paul writes for I delivered to
you the Christians of Corinth as of
first importance this is foundational
information what I also received and
here's where the Creed starts that
Christ died for our sins according to
the scriptures and that he was buried
and that he was raised on the third day
according to the scriptures and that he
appeared to sephus that's Peter then to
the 12 after that he appeared to more
than 500 Brethren at one time Paul is
writing this years later so he adds
parenthetically most of whom remain
until now but some have fallen asleep
then he appeared to James then to all
the apostles the original would have
ended with this appearance to all the
apostles but Jesus appeared to Paul
later so Paul adds and last of all as to
one untimely born he appeared to me also
notice what we have here we have Jesus
death for sins his burial his
resurrection on the third day and
numerous appearances and we have all of
it as authoritative tradition within a
few years if not within months of the
crucifixion as for the appearances there
are appearances to individuals Peter
James the brother of Jesus and
eventually Paul to small groups the 12
and all the apostles
and to a large group he appeared to more
than
500 the list also reports appearances to
both friends and foes Peter and the
apostles were followers of Jesus during
his three-year Ministry but James and
Paul weren't James didn't believe that
his brother was the Messiah when Jesus
was preaching in Galilee and Judea and
Paul persecuted the church and tried to
destroy it yet they're all listed as
Witnesses who saw Jesus alive again
sometime after his death this passage
eliminates two skeptical responses to
Jesus resurrection the legend hypothesis
and the hallucination hypothesis at the
internet level there are still people
who claim that Christian belief in Jesus
resurrection arose through a process of
legendary development over a period of
many
decades but this is factually false we
know as a fact of history that the
resurrection was the heart of Christian
preaching from the
beginning you also may have heard people
argue that Jesus disciples simply
hallucinated the resurrection
appearances but a hallucination by
definition is something that occurs in
the mind of the person experiencing it
if you take a bunch of acid and a
leprechaun appears to you the rest of us
aren't going to ask him for his pot of
gold because we won't see him he won't
exist outside your acid tripping mind
but Jesus appeared to entire groups on
multiple occasions and hallucinations
just can't explain repeated group
appearances so we can't attribute the
resurrection appearances to legend or to
hallucinations can we attribute them to
deception were the disciples lying about
the
appearances that's what I thought before
I was a Christian
but there's a fatal flaw in the
deception hypothesis Liars make poor
Martyrs while some human beings are
willing to die for what they believe in
I've never met anyone who was willing to
die for something he made up in the book
of Acts chapter 4 Peter and John are
arrested and threatened in Acts 5 the
apostles are put in jail and fogged in
Acts 12 James the brother of John is put
to death by Herod and Peter is again put
in jail the Apostle Paul describes his
life as a Christian in 2 Corinthians
11:2
24-27 he writes five times I received
from the Jews the 40 Lashes minus one
three times I was beaten with rods once
I was pelted with stones three times I
was Shipwrecked I spent a night and a
day in the open sea I've been constantly
on the move I've been in danger from
rivers in danger from bandits in danger
from my fellow Jews in danger from
Gentiles in danger in the city in danger
in the country in danger at Sea and in
danger from false Believers I have
labored and toiled and have often Gone
without sleep I've known hunger and
thirst and have often Gone without food
I've been cold and naked the Jewish
historian Josephus reports that James
the brother of Jesus was stoned to death
at as a law breaker Clement of Rome
invites his readers to keep in mind the
sufferings and martyrdoms of Peter and
Paul so the apostles didn't just preach
that they had seen Jesus alive again
they were willing to endure prison
floggings and even death as they
preached and that means they really
believed what they were
saying here again it's not just
Christians who draw this conclusion even
non-christians maintain that the
disciples sincerely believed that they
had seen the Risen Jesus gett ludeman it
may be taken as historically certain
that Peter and the disciples had
experiences after Jesus death in which
Jesus appeared to them as the Risen
Christ Bart man we can say with complete
certainty that some of his disciples at
some later time insisted that he soon
appeared to them convincing them that he
had been raised from the dead Bart ER
again it is a historical fact that some
of Jesus followers came to believe that
he had been raised from the dead soon
after his execution Paula Frederickson I
know in their own terms what they saw
was the raised Jesus I'm not saying that
they really did see the raised Jesus I
wasn't there I don't know what they saw
but I do know as a historian that they
must must have seen something
Frederickson says that she doesn't know
what they
saw but I do I think it's obvious what
they saw the disciples saw the sort of
thing that would convince individuals
and groups friends and foes that they
had all seen a man who had been dead
alive again standing in front of them
telling them why he had to die and Rise
Again
unfortunately for our atheist friends
the only sort of thing that can do that
is Jesus actually appearing to them
which means that Jesus rose from the
dead so there's only one conclusion to
draw from the facts that even atheist
and agnostic Scholars Grant as
historically certain and yet atheist and
agnostic Scholars clearly don't believe
that Jesus rose from the
dead why do they reject the resurrection
when they're aware of the historical
evidence different people will give
different reasons for denying Jesus
resurrection but if you do a little
digging two broad issues emerge most
frequently first many people have a
prior commitment to
naturalism Supernatural explanations are
ruled out before the investigation
begins and if Supernatural explanations
are ruled out beforehand Jesus
resurrection is never even a candidate
for
belief so is a commitment to naturalism
a good reason to reject the
resurrection as Alvin plena and others
have shown naturalism as a world view is
fundamentally incoherent because it ends
up undermining the reliability of the
cognitive faculties required to affirm
it if naturalism is true how did you
obtain your cognitive faculties the
processes that produce your
beliefs there's really only one game in
town if you're a naturalist your ability
to reason is the product of natural
selection acting on random
mutation natural selection of course
favors traits that help organisms
survive and reproduce so if human
reasoning evolved naturally it's because
it helped human beings survive and
reproduce does this give us any basis
for trusting our re reasoning ability
when it comes to questions of theology
or philosophy or
science no at best our cognitive
faculties would be reliable when it
comes to finding berries or using a
spear against an enemy or doing
something to attract a
mate interestingly Darwin himself
noticed this problem he said but with me
the horrid doubt always arises whether
the convictions of man's mind which has
been developed from the mind of the
lower animals are of any value or at all
trustworthy would anyone trust in the
convictions of a monkey's mind if there
are any convictions in such a
mind naturalism isn't a pillar of
rationality it's a Pillager of
rationality but a more glaring
difficulty given a discussion of
Miracles is the global abundance of
Miracle claim
in 2006 the Pew Forum issued a report
titled spirit and power a 10 country
survey of Pentecostals discussing
statistics on Pentecostals and
charismatic Protestants in the United
States Brazil Chile Guatemala Kenya
Nigeria South Africa India the
Philippines and South Korea and the
researchers found that approximately 200
million Pentecostal and charismatic
Protestants in just those 10 countries
believe that they have personally
witnessed miraculous
healings imagine what the numbers would
be if the study had included all
denominations in all countries in a 2022
article for the New York Times Dr Molly
worin writes Scholars estimate that 80%
of new Christians in Nepal come to the
faith through an experience with healing
or deliverance from demonic spirits
perhaps as many as 90% of new converts
who join a house Church in China credit
their conversion to Faith healing in
Kenya 71% of Christians say they have
witnessed a Divine Healing according to
a 2006 Pew study even in the relatively
skeptical United States 29% of survey
respondents claim they have seen one
after reviewing a number of Miracle
reports from around the world Dr Craig
Keener concl includes it is no longer
plausible to tout uniform human
experience as a basis for denying
Miracles as in the traditional modern
argument hundreds of millions of claims
would have to be satisfactorily
explained in nons Supernatural terms for
this appeal to succeed while many may be
so explained one cannot adopt the
conclusion of uniformity as a premise
without investigating all of them in
other words those who exclude
Supernatural explanations prior to
investigation do so by faith not because
the evidence demands it second it's
perhaps even more common to reject the
resurrection because of what the
resurrection
implies if we believe that Jesus rose
from the dead we might think it's a good
idea to listen to what he says but Jesus
said all kinds of things about Sin and
judgment and salvation and if we don't
want to take his teachings seriously or
if we don't want to become Christians or
if we despise anything that has any
connection to Christianity we kind of
need to get rid of that whole rising
from the dead
thing now this has always seemed like an
odd approach to me decide what we want
to believe ahead of time and then reject
evidence that doesn't line up with what
we want to believe and atheists normally
condemn this approach suppose an atheist
comes to you with some kind of evidence
let's say he gives you evidence for
common dissent the claim that all living
things share a common
ancestor if your response is well I
don't like what common descent implies
because that would mean I'm related to
pigs so I'm going to reject any evidence
you give me for it the atheist will
accuse you of being anti-science and
anti- evidence and irrational and stupid
and bigoted and so on but then if you
present that same atheist with evidence
that Jesus rose from the dead you'll
suddenly find that heaven and hell and
the Salem witch trials and gay wedding
cakes and all kinds of other topics are
entering into his evaluation of whether
Jesus was dead and whether he was alive
again
later feelings become the ultimate trump
card we obviously can't stop our atheist
friends from smuggling their feelings
about Christianity into discussions of
historical facts about Jesus but we can
point out how ridiculous it is for them
to claim to be the champions of reason
and Science and logic when their
feelings and emotions have full Reign
Over their
reasoning now there's other evidence
that's relevant to this discussion and
there are additional objections to
consider but we already have enough to
conclude that Jesus rose from the dead
all the available evidence tells us that
Jesus died by crucifixion and that he
was alive again later friends and foes
were so thoroughly convinced that Jesus
had appeared to them that they were
willing to endure torture and death for
the privilege of proclaiming the
Christian
message the question for us is this
what could have convinced all these
people that Jesus had appeared to
them this is the question I struggled
with almost three decades ago and I
couldn't think of any explanation apart
from the resurrection that could account
for the historical
evidence by that time I already knew
that naturalism was a theory and
crisis and I didn't trust my feelings
enough to reject facts I didn't
like in the end I concluded that Jesus
of Nazareth rose from the dead and that
if I was going to listen to anyone tell
me about
God it was
[Music]
him